>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Cole: Good morning, and
welcome to the Library of Congress.
My name is John Cole.
I'm the director of the Center for
the Book in the Library of Congress,
which is privileged to be able
to host this program today.
I'm going to say a few words
about both the Library of Congress
as an institution and the Center for
the Book's program in just a couple
of minutes, but in
order to get us started
and to get some important
logistical information,
I'm pleased to introduce Lisa Cone.
Lisa is the director
of program expansion
for the National Campaign
to Stop Violence.
Let's welcome Lisa.
[ Applause ]
>> Lisa Cone: Thank
you, and good morning.
I would like to welcome you on
behalf of the National Campaign
to Stop Violence and to thank
Mr. John Cole from the Library
of Congress for hosting this event.
It's always such a
highlight of our program.
As he said, my name is Lisa Cone,
and you've all met me at this point,
a lot, but this morning, as we get
started, I wanted to make mention
of several people who are here.
I wanted to recognize them.
First of all, Dan Callister,
if you just want to stand up.
[ Applause ]
All of you have had the chance
yesterday to hear from him
and meet him, and again,
just wanted to let you know
that he is the chairman and
founder of the National Campaign
to Stop Violence and the
visionary behind this program,
so we thank him.
We also have with us today
Dr. Hassan Al-Ebraheem,
who is the chairman and founder.
Dr. Ebraheem.
Dr. Hassan.
[ Applause ]
He is the chairman and founder
of the Kuwait-America Foundation,
and Dr. Hassan, we'd
especially like recognize you
for all the work you've done in
education, especially education
for children both here
and in Kuwait.
And completing our distinguished
guests today is Mr. Fawzi Al-Sultan.
[ Applause ]
Mr. Al-Sultan's business acumen
has led him to hold many positions
with international cooperation in
agency, and he is a board member
of the Kuwait-America Foundation
and has been a strong advocate
of our program, and we thank you
for that, and thank all of you
for joining us this morning
in spite of the wet weather.
You know, presenting the National
Book of Writing to the Library
of Congress, as I mentioned, is
always such a great privilege
and such a great highlight
of our week.
I don't know if many of you
had a chance when you walked
into the library today
to see anything.
We are going to give
you time afterward,
but I'm sure you can feel the
magnificence of this building
and gotten a glimpse of just what
an awesome place this is, and now,
your writings are going
to be here in the library,
so I just think that's
the coolest thing ever.
You are going to be doing
something that I have never done.
You are going to be here along with
all the great writers of America,
and yesterday, when you
received your business cards,
as Judge Woodruff said,
on those business cards,
it says that you were
a national ambassador.
And you really are
national ambassadors,
because you are representing your
city, you're representing your peers
and all of the stories that
they have to tell as well.
And now, on that business card,
you can add the title of author,
because you are going to have your
writings in the Library of Congress,
and years from now, you can
come back and look for them
with your children,
with your grandchildren,
with your great-grandchildren,
because they will be here
for all time, here in the library.
Mr. John Cole, who
started the program,
has really made this a
reality, and so we thank him.
John is a librarian and a historian,
and he has dedicated his career
toward forwarding the role
of the Library of Congress in
both American society and culture.
His career began at the
library, and he's still here
and is currently the director
of the Center for the Book.
John's favorite two
projects, he tells me,
are to oversee the National Book
Festival, which happens here
in Washington in September,
usually in the fall,
and the Young Readers Center.
John also tells me that he has
two heroes, Thomas Jefferson
and George Washington,
and Thomas Jefferson
because he was actually one of the
first people who was instrumental
in getting the library
started, and George Washington
because John has quite a history
with the name of Washington.
He was born in Washington state.
He attended the University
of Washington.
Then he moved to Washington, DC.
He attended George
Washington University.
And so I think that qualifies
him to be a Washingtonian.
Anyway, John, we would love
to turn the time over to you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Thank you, Lisa.
I would just like to say a
couple of words about the Library
of Congress itself and about
the Center for the Book,
and I will add another favorite to
my list of favorites that I gave
to Lisa, and that is I'm also
fortunate to be the chair
of a new Library of
Congress program,
the Library of Congress Literacy
Awards, and the literacy part
of that effort is very close to
what the Center for the Book does.
We were created in 1977 by Daniel
Boorstin when he was the Librarian
of Congress as a public-private
partnership to use the Library
of Congress, and its prestige,
and its size, and its resources,
and its wonderful staff to
stimulate public interest
in reading and in books.
This was before there was a
lot of attention to a subject
such as literacy, so it's
natural that now as the work
of literacy grows more
and more important
that we take on this
literacy effort.
Lisa did mention the
Young Readers Center.
That is a part of what we do.
We administer the first
place in the Library
of Congress dedicated
to serving young people.
It's actually in this building,
and I hope you get a chance
to at least walk by it
when you tour the building.
It's three beautifully redesigned
rooms that are aimed not only at
but for kids, people 16 and under,
as long as they're accompanied
by an adult, and we feature
programming and school visits,
and it's an important
part of what we do.
We also have chapters or
affiliates in every state,
and one of my hopes is that
we can combine our partnership
with this program on occasion with
cities or with programs that are
in cities around the program, but
that is really for the future,
but we're very pleased that we
can have a part in hosting you
and have a role in making
certain that your writings,
as Lisa has already mentioned,
are part of this great collection.
I'll conclude with
just a couple of words
about the Library of
Congress itself.
It really is part of
America's history.
We were the first federal
cultural organization
to be created in our country.
We were created in 1800, before the
capitol even came to Washington.
Congress created us while
they were in Philadelphia,
but they knew they
were headed for DC,
and the very first building
we were in was the US capitol.
In fact, the Library of
Congress was part of the capitol
for our whole first century, from
1800 until the building that you are
in today, named the Thomas
Jefferson Building, was opened.
Congress needed books,
Congress needed information,
so they needed the Library, but
what's unique about the Library
of Congress -- a couple of things.
One is it is the largest
library in the world.
It, along with the Smithsonian,
and today, the National Archives,
really are the three big cultural
institutions that watch over
and promote American
culture and American history.
We're a little different
in that we're also the
parliamentary library,
and there's something
wonderful about that,
because Congress recognized it
needed books and information,
but when Thomas Jefferson, one of
my favorite people, as you now know,
realized that the British had
burned the capitol in 1814,
as part of the War of 1812,
and it had destroyed the little
tiny Library of Congress,
he asked Congress to purchase
his great private library,
which covered, many, many
different subjects, and Congress did
so to get us started again in 1815.
But Jefferson had an idea
which has come to fruition.
He said not only would this
be the best place for Congress
to get information as a
parliamentary library,
but by the way, this great
collection should be open
to the American people as well.
We're a democracy.
Everyone needs information,
everyone needs to know what is
in this organization, and it turned
out that after the Civil War,
the Library of Congress
was able to develop
into a great public institution
as well, and it's the public side
of the Library that the
Center for the Book is really,
in a sense, most concerned about.
It's the outreach.
It's educating people about
the importance of the role
of the Library of Congress and
the role it can play in reaching
out to people of all ages, you
know, to be part of society
and to facing some of the
difficulties and wonderful
but difficult situations
we are facing as a culture
as our civilization grows and
matures and as our country grows.
And it's through literacy,
and through reading promotion,
and through program support of a
program such as Do the Write Thing
that the Center for the Book is the
vehicle of reaching out on behalf
of the Library of Congress to
let you know that we are here,
that we have these magnificent
resources that are paid
for basically by the
American taxpayer.
And one of our big tasks is to share
these resources, and a sub part
of that is letting people know about
them through programs such as this.
So again, it's a great
pleasure to have you here
and it will be a great pleasure
to help facilitate bringing your
writings into the collections
of the largest and most
diverse library in the world.
I am now turning it
back over to Lisa.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Lisa Cone: So yesterday, Dan
Callister had the chance to meet
with the students and get to
know them a little better,
and as he just told me,
many of you told him,
at least half of you
told him that one
of your favorite activities
was reading, so we're delighted
to hear that, and I'm sure
John Cole is delighted
to hear how much reading is a part
of the things that you like to do.
We've had many very
exceptional writings this year,
and I wish that we could hear
from all of you, but as you know,
life is just full of choices,
and so we had to make
some very difficult ones
in selecting the essays that
are going to be read today.
First, we are going to hear from
Jason Woods, who is an eight grader
from Charlotte, North Carolina.
Next, we will hear from Maya Monson,
who is an eighth grader
in Palm Beach.
She will be followed by Safi Ghani
[phonetic], who is an eighth grader
from Beaumont, and then
concluding will be Fabiola Paloma,
who is a seventh grader
from Chicago.
So Jason, we'll ask
you to come up first.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello. Okay.
"Do the Write Thing" by Jason Woods.
Drugs are everywhere -- schools,
work, business and even churches.
There is not a place in America
that doesn't have any type
of drug-related violence resource.
For example, ask an older adult
about the drug and violence
that occurred during their
period of growing up.
Nine times out of ten, they
will tell you a very long
and breathtaking story,
and it's only getting worse
as each day goes by.
Almost every child in America has
had a drug-related experience.
Drugs are everywhere,
even in video games.
With these drugs being very
common in people's everyday lives,
kids and teenagers
often get exposed to it,
whether it is at a party
or social gathering.
The most common drug is tobacco.
Once a child is exposed, they
will consider smoking as well.
As they get older, they will
get exposed to marijuana,
which will lead them to think it's
just like smoking a cigarette.
How do I know this?
Because I was that kid at
elementary school along
with the other 500-plus students.
Even if you sit down and talk
to children and adults about it,
that doesn't mean that
they don't do drugs
or that it doesn't
even cross their mind.
As much experience as I've had with
drugs, that doesn't necessary mean
that the thought of it does not
run through my mind as well.
Growing up in a single-parent home
where our mother is doing the
best she can to raise me not to be
like my father is very difficult.
On April 2nd, 2005, my father
committed suicide due to drugs.
In fact, he died by taking a
prescribed drug given by the doctor.
I heard stories about my mom having
to go into the crack house just
to find my dad at the
late hours of the night,
having breathtaking moments every
time the phone rang and he wasn't
at home -- and saying a short prayer
to herself every time the phone
rang and he wasn't at home.
I'm sorry.
Hold up. I kind of
just mixed up that.
Having breathtaking moments every
time the phone rang and he wasn't
at home and saying a
short prayer to herself,
hoping it wasn't the police
calling saying he was found dead,
or having to keep looking
out the window,
making sure the police
weren't at the door looking
for him to have a drug raid.
This really took a toll
on her and my family.
Me being young at the time, I didn't
really know what was happening.
At his funeral, I remember standing
in the chair during the
21-gun salute and staring
at the casket waiting
for him to wake
up because I thought he was
just pretending to be asleep.
It seemed very surreal.
While this was happening, I
was wondering why everybody
around me was crying while wearing
black, with their faces puffy
and colors purple mixed
with blue under their skin.
Now, it seems just
like a faint memory.
That was the past, and it
cannot be taken back or undone.
Because of this traffic incident
that occurred, I try my best not
to fall under peer pressure
or get taken advantage of.
During my adult years, I'm
going to be the best role model
for my nephew that I can be.
My nephew was born a
prenatal exposed infant,
better known as a crack baby.
During the nine months he was
developing during his mother's
pregnancy, she was raped
and also sold her body
for drugs such as cocaine.
With this affecting
his mental growth,
he still cannot talk fluently,
acts like a baby, and still demands
for the bottle known as Similac.
Now he has to undergo continuous
mental and physical therapy.
Due to this, he will always
be different than his peers.
That's why I'm going to be
there whenever he is down,
in need of comfort and steer him in
the right path so he will not have
to rely on the use of drugs
just for him to get by in life.
Take a moment and actually
think to yourself:
What have you actually
done to prevent the usage
and consumption of drugs?
Besides -- I'm sorry.
Take a moment to actually
think to yourself:
What have people actually done to
prevent the usage and consumption
of drugs besides giving an
hour-long speech about why it is bad
for your health and all the
cancerous diseases it can cause?
Though it is 100 percent correct,
just by talking to people,
that does not mean they will have
to listen to what you have to say.
The only way to actively change a
person's personal opinion and point
of view is by getting
physically involved
in the community and in their lives.
Many of the ones holding
seminars and protesting
about the harmful drugs and
intakes do not really do anything
that could change someone's mind
besides speak and hold up signs.
What I mean by changing someone's
mind is actually showing them what
it's like to live a drug-addicted
life by taking them to a crack house
and showing them the reality of
what it's like to be addicted
to such a life-consuming product.
The experience I've had with these
drugs is very graphic and a hard
and emotional topic to talk about.
The only thing I can do right
now at this age is tell my story
about my life-consuming
encounters and pray
that the person I'm telling listens
about all the problems just one
little consumption of drugs can do
and how it can ruin your
life with just one puff
of smoke or snort of cocaine.
Actually, this essay that I'm
writing right now helped my friend
last night while she was
on the verge of suicide.
Just by me telling my story
and how it is affecting
my life helped save hers,
and now she thanks me every time
she sees me because she did not know
that I went through these
incidents growing up.
Every day I wake up,
put a smile on my face,
and try not to let the
past experiences degrade me
and make me feel any
less than myself,
all because of one little intake
of cocaine that my father consumed.
I try to see it as a cry for help.
Just because he did not get the
attention he needed does not make
him any less of a true hero he is.
I never knew that this common drug
could affect my life like it did,
and now I will continue my life,
growing up happy and drug free.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello. "Do the Write
Thing" by Maya Monson.
I watched as he hit her over
and over, pounding his fist
into her face, back, arms
-- anywhere he could reach.
The sound was sickening.
She yelled out in pain,
trying to grab
or hit him, but she was too slow.
Tears streaked down her face, and
she went limp and just gave up.
I was shaking and crying,
screaming and pleading
for him to stop hurting my mom.
All that did was make him
focus his attention on me.
He yelled at me and then started
hitting her again while I ran
up to my room.
This was my life.
I wasn't even six years old.
One day, I went to the
neighbor's and was molested.
I was told not to tell anyone.
I felt absolutely disgusting,
but I was told not to tell,
and that's what I saw my mom
did every -- every day, yeah.
So why was I to be ashamed?
I was only six.
I remember when my mother
slit her wrists with a knife
and blood was pouring out of her,
but her boyfriend wasn't helping.
Once again, I wasn't even six, and
I was crying and trying to help,
but my eyes were blurred, and
she wasn't able to speak properly
because of the substance abuse.
I was put in my room
by him and stayed
up crying until I fell asleep.
I guess you could say I've been
dealt a pretty repulsive set
of cards, and though it has
affected my life negatively,
it has also helped me grow.
I have depression, anxiety and
borderline personality disorder
as well as a bunch of bad habits
that are hard to overcome,
though I am working
on overcoming them.
However, thanks to my
past, I can help others
with problems of all kinds.
I want to be a psychologist
for severely abused children.
Bullying has taken
a toll on my life.
It is inevitable, no
matter who you are.
However, it amazes me how low
people will stoop to engage
in unacceptable behavior
to satisfy their own needs.
I mean we are all going
through the same things.
Our bodies are changes, our voices,
our interests, our friend groups.
How does that make anyone
better than anyone else?
Youth violence as well as any other
type of violence is routed back
to many things -- broken homes,
social networking, gangs,
substance abuse, poverty, peer
pressure, ignorance, and many more.
All violence is routed
back to something.
Teens with mental illnesses tend
to show a marked propensity
for violent behaviors.
Once you start, I know how
hard it can be to stop.
Violence overcomes you.
According to the Center for
Disease Control and Prevention,
about 32 percent of teens have
been bullied or have been bullies.
Those teens are more likely to
skip school and start fights.
Without knowing the causes, how
are we to stop youth violence?
First, we need to be educated.
Violence is hard for
you to stop by yourself.
Trust me. I've tried.
There are a few things
that you could do to help.
Violence is a serious issue.
If you see someone
getting bullied, step in.
Now, I'm not saying
go get yourself hurt.
I'm saying if you see
a situation escalating,
get someone to go help the person.
Give respect so you get respect.
If 70 percent of people
remembered this,
there wouldn't be nearly
as many fights.
Think "What would your family say?"
as a big part is as parents, adults
need to be there for the children.
Though my mother couldn't take
care of herself much less a child,
she always tried to care for me.
Though this isn't the best, she
worked at a gentleman's club,
and she split up half of the money
for drugs and half of the money
for me, but she loved me
and she showed it somehow.
Teachers should always teach
the benefits and practices
of leading a nonviolent lifestyle.
Without this, students may
never learn, considering most
of us assume we already know.
Know that youth violence has caused
738,000 young people ages ten to 24
to be treated with assault-related
injuries, according to the CDC.
Though youth violence is a huge
problem -- we all know it is --
I feel we can come together and
reduce the percent of violent teens.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay. Every day -- sorry.
Every day, wherever I go,
whether it is the mall, school,
or movies, I experience violence.
Though the level of violence I
experience may be very minor,
like a dispute between neighbors,
there are much worse cases
of violence around the world.
In my opinion, the biggest issue
of violence is Islamic terrorism.
I believe terroristic violence
is a result of religious
and cultural misunderstandings
between different diverse groups.
These differences have
led to so much violence.
For example, al-Qaeda
purpose is to destroy America
for they believe the way America
governs and their standard
of living wasn't just or righteous.
They have no idea how
great a place America is
to live and raise a family.
I'm sorry.
One sec. Okay.
They have no idea how great
a place America is to live
and raise a family, so they
carried out 9/11 to show America
that they were superior and
to try and break America.
Can you imagine having a loved
one killed for no reason at all?
That's what thousands of Americans
had to go through that day.
Even though I did not lose a loved
one, my life was changed forever.
How could someone in the
name of my faith, Islam,
do something so terrible?
I know from what my parents and
religious teachers have taught was
that Islam is a religion of
peace, acceptance and respect.
My dad has always taught
me to try and understand
and respect people's
differences of faith.
Instead of practicing
Islam as it was meant to
or respecting the differences
between American culture
and their own twisted view of Islam,
Osama bin Laden, leader of al-Qaeda,
considered his culture superior,
and on 9/11, al-Qaeda carried
out their attacks on
the Twin Towers.
Being an American Muslim,
these terrorist groups are
impacting my life greatly.
At school, I would
always get bullied
and teased because of my religion.
Towel-head, camel jockey, and other
more vulgar names have been told,
or more like yelled at me.
When walking through the mall,
people would stare at my family
and give us dirty looks because
of my mother's head scarf.
We even flew an American
flag, but many people
in our neighborhood would
still give us dirty looks.
Did they not realize that I am as
upset about what happened also?
These terrorist groups are
attacking my complete way of life.
I am an American and Muslim.
Just as al-Qaeda is not trying to
understand America's way of life,
a lot of people here are
guilty of the same thing also.
The television news and
newspapers are selling headlines,
only worried about getting
ratings, but not caring
that they are misinforming
the public.
If people would research
the religion on their own,
they would realize that these
terrorists are crazy people acting
barbarically, hiding
under the banner of Islam,
just like the KKK hid under
the banner of Christianity.
I know that no God-fearing
Christian would agree with the KKK.
Despite all these hardships
I go through,
I never stop being a proud American
and a strong practicing Muslim.
And please don't get me wrong.
There were a lot of good
people who provided support
and stuck up for my family.
I realize that I can't stop
the violence that is happening,
but I can try being a
bridge between Muslims'
and Americans' misunderstandings.
Having an understanding of both
an American way of life and Islam,
I am in the perfect position to
teach both Americans and Muslims.
It is my job to properly
explain and teach people
that Islam is not the
enemy, but the crazy people
who are committing violent acts
under the misrepresented
view of Islam.
Also, I can explain and teach
Muslims how great this country is
to live in and the
freedom that we have.
It is in this freedom that
has made practicing Islam
so great in America.
I can only imagine what
would happen to me if I were
to express these thoughts as
a student in the Middle East.
I can also help start interfaith
conferences, where all types
of people can get together
and learn about each other.
I know that these violent terrorist
groups will always be around,
but I will do my best
to try and teach people
that there are better ways to live.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> "Last One Standing"
by Fabiola Paloma.
Waking up, stepping out with fear.
Around the corner,
bullets can interfere.
I see my five friends,
they say hello.
A car passes by, I yell, "Down low!"
It goes away, and no one is hurt.
Our knees and faces
covered with dirt.
Waking up, stepping out with fear.
Around the corner,
bullets can interfere.
I see my four friends,
they say hello.
The fifth one is out
making easy money.
Our minds are confused,
but I stand my ground.
I am not thinking of
going that away around.
Waking up, stepping out with fear.
Around the corner,
bullets can interfere.
I see my three friends,
they say hello.
The fourth one didn't make it home.
Our minds are set,
we need to survive,
but I'm thinking further
of how to get out alive.
Waking up, stepping out with fear.
Around the corner,
bullets can interfere.
I see my two friends,
they say hello.
The third one is out in a war.
One side is black,
the other is white.
The two colors that
can't seem to combine.
No one knows why they
can't think alike.
Our minds are tired but
have not surrendered.
We wonder if we'll
make it out uninjured.
Waking up, stepping out with fear.
Around the corner,
bullets can interfere.
I see my friend, he says hello.
The second one is in
jail, and the reason?
No one knows.
The police said he
committed a felony
but didn't specifically say what.
Our minds are convinced the
authority isn't with us.
Not all are bad but
nor are they good.
I can't say they all do a good
job like the way they should.
Waking up, stepping
out without care.
Around the corner,
anything can happen.
I see none of my friends,
no one but me.
I am the last one standing but weak.
I am convinced I will fall,
until I look into the eyes
of the person reading this now.
My last chance of hope.
My last chance of survival.
A cry for help will not
do, no one will listen.
Except maybe you.
[ Applause ]
>> Lisa Cone: Thank you to
the four students who read.
I know that took a lot of courage
in front of this many people
to share a very personal
part of your life with us,
and we do thank you for
sharing and for your insight
into what the problems of violence
are doing to youth in America.
Mr. David Esquith is the
director of the Office
of Safe and Healthy Students.
His office is in the Department
of Education, and he reports
to the Secretary of Education,
who is Secretary Arne Duncan.
Mr. Esquith has been the
director there for several years.
Prior to that, he serve in the
Office of Special Education
in rehabilitation service,
and something that I learned
about David several years ago is
that when he had his
business cards created,
he actually had them
printed in Braille so that
when he gave them out, it would
bring attention to this area
of education, and I thought
that was a pretty cool idea.
He has worked as a special
education teacher, an administrator,
a lobbyist, a congressional
aide, and a Peace Corps volunteer
in North Africa, which he says was
the best two years of his life.
He said he thought that because he
didn't have a care in the world,
but I think he enjoyed that time
so much because in the Peace Corps,
he was fully engaged in
serving others, and this service
from the time of the Peace
Corps until now is something
that has been a hallmark
of David's career.
So David?
[ Applause ]
>> David Esquith: Thank you, Lisa.
Thank you, and good morning to
everyone, and as I was coming
in on the train this morning, I was
remembering this is my fourth year
of doing this, and it
really is a pleasure,
and I've read through
all of the essays.
I really admire and
congratulate all of you.
The essays are so candid, so
honest, and the resilience of all
of you is just quite admirable, so
I want to congratulate all of you,
and to share a few thoughts,
a few thoughts on character,
and I wouldn't be in the
Department of Education
if I didn't start with
a bit of a quiz.
I know it's summer
break, but this is a quiz
or just a question that'll give
you a little insight into, perhaps,
who you are or kind of what
character you have, and so,
you know, it's a bit
of a parlor game.
The question is if
you had a super power.
You can have a super power,
and I'm giving you two choices.
You can be invisible,
or you can fly.
Okay, so think about
that for a moment.
You can have a superpower.
You can be invisible,
or you can fly.
Just want to take a
poll, a raise of hands.
How many people would
like to be invisible.
Raise your hand.
A lot of adults, and I think
that probably has something
to do with the kids.
As a parent of two nine-year-olds,
for any number of reasons,
I often wish that I were invisible,
both not to be there as well
as to find out what's going on.
And then how many people
would prefer to fly?
Yeah, lots of kids,
lots of young people.
All right, so when you
process this question,
what you're doing is thinking
about kind of who you are,
and if you had this superpower,
what life would be like,
and how good it would feel.
So we all have, everyone
has, a unique character,
and I'm going to run through
some slides on character,
and there are some
questions built in here,
and I think there's one question
at the end that I really want you
to come away with and think about,
and I want to credit two people.
I want to credit Tiffany Schlain,
who is kind of the founder
of The Moxie Institute, and
there's a film called The Science
of Character.
I encourage you all to go online.
You'll see a lot of the concepts
from my presentation today
from that film, and I also
want to credit a person.
Someone who's been here for
four years who has seen some
of my presentations before,
and I see some familiar faces,
will know that this is really
an upgrade for me in terms
of my slide presentation, and
I want to credit Eric Sherwin.
Eric, can you stand up for a moment?
Who's with the Department
of Education this summer.
[ Applause ]
So you'll see that I
couldn't have done these.
I don't know how Eric did it, but --
so we're going to talk a little bit
about character, and
the question is, "Well,
what determines character?
What determines who
we are as people?"
and people, and science, and
philosophers have been kind
of asking this question
for an awful long time,
and there's some new thinking
on it, and some thinking
that I think has a lot of
implications for stopping violence,
and preventing violence,
and how we treat each other,
and the answer is "you do."
You determine your character,
and it is a very powerful,
powerful idea that you have control
over the kind of person who are you.
The other component to
this is that the people
around you help determine your
character, and the converse
to that is that you help determine
the character of other people
by the way that you
interact with them.
And so the idea here is that
if you focus on certain parts
of who you are, you can
develop your character.
We all have many different
parts, right.
We all are good.
We all are bad.
We have good moments, we have bad
moments, things we're proud of,
things we're ashamed of,
and part of this comes
down to what you focus
on as a person.
For a long time, and this is
still kind of prevalent in a lot
of the ways that we deal with
people, in particular people
at school and issues
around disruption --
is we focus on what's wrong with
someone, what's the problem,
what's wrong with that person, how
can we fix what's wrong with them,
and in 2004, Christopher
Peterson and Martin Seligman came
up with kind of a different
paradigm, and it's not something
that was totally new, but
they said, "Why don't we focus
on what's right with a person?
When we're talking to a person, why
don't we focus on their strengths
and what's right with them,
and what impact will that have
on how society deals with
everyone in the society?"
And so scientists being what
they are came up with a table,
so science kind of organizes
things by tables, right,
and so there was a Periodic Table of
Character Strengths, and I want you
to kind of take a look at the
headings across the table,
and then take a look at
the parts underneath,
and start thinking about yourself.
What are your strengths
under these categories?
And the categories are wisdom,
courage, humanity, justice,
temperance, and transcendence.
And so take a look
at kind of the boxes.
I hope you can all --
can everybody see those?
[ Inaudible Audience Response ]
But I don't want to take up too
much time going through all of them,
but under those categories,
think of your strengths.
Think of people in your life
and their strengths that fit
under these categories, and
what science has learned is
that there are seven that really
keep coming up over and over again
in terms of people who
are successful and happy,
and those seven are optimism,
gratitude, social intelligence,
curiosity, self-control, enthusiasm,
and perseverance, and that people
who have one or more of
these qualities and who focus
on strengthening those qualities
are the people who are more likely
to become successful and happy.
So think about, again, those parts
of yourself, where you have one
or more of those characteristics.
Think about other people that
you know, and think about ways,
and here's one of the keys here, of
what you can do to increase that,
to improve that, to build
out those character traits.
So see, this is Eric.
I never would have come
up with this slide.
I got to give Eric credit here.
And so we're all -- I mean we're
all kind of this patchwork quilt,
but everyone has a unique
combination of traits,
and if we focus on
building strengths,
then that has a lasting
impact if we focus on,
"What are the strengths
of this person?"
So I'm the principal.
Some kid comes down.
He's been sent down to
the principal's office.
He's disrupted the class.
What happens when the principal
goes, "I know this student.
What are his strengths?
What can we do to kind of
improve his strengths?"
Then we end up having a much more
lasting impact in our interactions
with people than if we start
working on what's the problem,
what's wrong with them, what do
I need to do to fix what's wrong,
and we help shape others'
characters, too.
So this is, again, this idea that
it's not just us, but what we do
as we interact with people
helps shape their character,
and that the key to human
relationships is appreciating
others' strengths, and I'll
let that sink in for a moment,
because it's really quite a
kind of a profound thought
about genuinely appreciating
other people's strengths,
people who we don't like,
people who rub us the wrong way,
where there's friction, where
there's kind of conflict.
What happens if the lens that
we look through is about,
"What are the strengths of
this person, and what can I do
to kind of appreciate them?"
And so if you improve your
character through mindful striving
or let your character worsen through
negligence and obliviousness,
then what we know is
that happiness comes
from practicing virtuous
character strengths,
and this idea of practicing
them is very real.
How do we practice
character strengths?
And I'll give you an example,
and this is kind of something
that it's an exercise that I
go through living in Washington
on a regular basis, and it's
little moments like these
where we're really kind of
practicing our character strengths,
but in Washington, unfortunately,
there are a lot of
homeless individuals.
There are a lot of individuals
who are out asking for money,
who are panhandling, and it
always makes me uncomfortable.
I'm always faced with
kind of a moral dilemma
when I see these individuals
on the street of,
"Do I take out a dollar
and give it to them?"
and this is kind of where
my character is surfacing.
These are kind of the little
moments in the course of the day
where your character is surfacing,
and I've always struggled with this.
It's that, you know,
kind of typical dilemma.
Well, if I give them a dollar,
am I reinforcing this behavior?
You know, I start going through
all these mental exercises of,
"Is this the right thing to do?
You know, this person,
am I encouraging them?
You know, they're making
me uncomfortable.
That's not right.
They're invading my space."
Just, you know, in just a moment's
time, you go through this kind
of continuum of emotions
about something
that is basically pretty simple, and
I was in a course at our synagogue,
and the rabbi was talking about
this, and what he said was that part
of the Jewish tradition in terms
of giving alms to the poor is
that you should always do it
when you least want to do it,
that at that moment, when this
is the last person that you want
to give a dollar to or some money
to who is begging for money,
that's when you should
give it to them.
And I've tried to live by
that, and it's just kind of one
of those moments, as I said,
in the course of the day
when our real character not
only kind of exhibits itself,
but it's kind of an opportunity
to develop it, an opportunity
to do something that kind of fits
within those seven categories
that they identified earlier.
So going back to the science here,
there's a science that, you know,
there's kind of a fixed mindset,
and there's a growth mindset,
that we're all kind of, once we're
born and through the first kind
of the formative years of
our lives, we are who we are.
We are who we're going to be.
There's another, I think, approach
to this, which really resonates
with me, which is to have a
growth mindset, that every day,
no matter how old you are, no
matter what your circumstances are,
you can grow as a person, that
we all can grow as a person.
And so with the fixed mindset,
as I said, it's kind of belief
that we're born with certain
abilities, intelligence,
and talents, and we're
stuck with it,
and I think a lot of
people believe that.
A lot of people, when they deal with
other people, particularly people
who they're having a conflict with,
they go, "That's who that person is,
and it's not going to change,
and I'm writing them off."
The growth mindset is I can change.
If I set my mind to it, I can do
anything, and that even failure
for me is something that I can learn
from, and that we can all develop.
So, you know, again, going back
to the science, they're kind of,
as they're studying the brain,
there's a lot of interesting brain
science coming out these days.
They talk about kind of executive
functions, and there's a part
of a brain where, you know, we've
got organizing, and prioritizing,
and sustaining efforts, and
accessibility, and memory,
and recall, and focusing on
tasks, and managing frustration
and emotions, and self-regulating
actions,
and this part of the
brain is dynamic.
It is constantly changing,
constantly growing,
and so here's an adage that I
hope you'll kind of keep in mind,
because again, kind of our
own personal experience,
how many of us kind of
perseverate on things?
We just kind of -- there's
this movie going on in our head
of something bad that's
going on in their lives,
and we spend an awful lot of time
kind of playing this movie over
and over again, and the takeaway
here is that has an effect on you.
It has an effect on who you are
and the character that you have.
And so this adage is that you
need to watch your thoughts.
They become your words.
Watch your words.
They become actions.
Watch your actions.
They become habits.
Watch your habits.
They become your character.
Watch your character.
It becomes your destiny.
And when you kind of follow
this sequence of just beginning
with your thoughts and
what we're thinking about,
and what we're focusing on, and the
ability to kind of stop those movies
that are negative, that are focusing
on what's wrong, what the problem is
with someone rather than the movie
of, "Well, what are their strengths?
What are my strengths?
What can I do to kind
of grow my strengths?"
By the time you kind of
finish the sequence of events,
your character kind of
determines your destiny,
and kind of the journey that we're
all on in life, and where we end up,
and you know, quite frankly,
I'm grateful that the journey
that I'm taking has given me the
opportunity to present to people
like you, to be exposed to kind
of the courageous good work
that you do, and so all of us
have control of our destiny,
and sometimes, it just begins
with our thoughts and our words.
So character strengths can be
learned, practiced and cultivated.
That's a takeaway here.
Focusing on your strengths
makes them stronger.
Focusing on others' strengths
makes them stronger, too.
And then the final thought, the
question that I try to ask myself
on kind of a regular basis
throughout the course of the day,
throughout the course of every
small interaction that I have
with other people, because that's
really kind of who I am, right.
We all are kind of the aggregation
of every small moment in our lives,
and so the question that really
I encourage you to ask yourself,
to take a moment and think: "Is
what I'm about do a reflection
of who I am and who I want to be?"
And if you do that, then I
can encourage you to think
that we'll all be a lot happier, and
safer, and it'll be a better world
for all of us to live in.
So thank you again
for this opportunity.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.